chainsaw man is Cinema and I don't say
that in jest this is a series that
manages to have a character that
literally has arcs where his sole goal
is to touch a whoa hello while also
delivering a complicated and nuanced
story about some pretty difficult
subject matters and now that this
extremely interesting anime adaptation
has caused the popularity of the series
to explode I think it's about time I
take a look at this season of the series
I love talk about its production voice
acting and story to see if it delivers
the experience I as a chainsaw man fan
was hoping for this is gonna be a long
one everyone so sit back grab some food
and dive into the Wacky World of
Fujimoto with me as I break down and
review what is currently one of the most
popular anime on the planet I'm totally
nutmmark and this is my review of
Chainsaw man season one
[Music]
introduction as I'm sure many of you out
there might be aware of already I've
actually written a comprehensive review
of the manga for this series on my
channel across three separate parts and
while I will be repeating some of my
thoughts on the narrative you can
consider this a One-Stop shop for my
thoughts on both the manga and the anime
itself with plenty of new material I
wanted to touch on concerning this anime
adaptation How It's Made where I think
its weaknesses are and how it managed to
produce one of the best episodes of
anime I've ever seen right out the gate
with this anime adaptation mappa makes
their presence felt I've complemented
their application and use of 3D assets
and models with the likes of Attack on
Titan's final season and this seems to
employ a lot of what made that feel
special too if not in a more subtle
fashion at least in this opening episode
anyway 3D particles floating in the air
offering a sense of depth and grounding
the scene in reality this alongside some
more subtle animation nods and you have
for yourself a very immersive first
episode and that's not even to mention
the absolutely incredible opening theme
animation which as of running this video
currently boasts over 57 million views
on YouTube it's a standout Smorgasbord
of Animation music character and color
that captures my interpretation of the
manga perfectly the vibrant splashes of
color remind me of the manga covers
themselves contrasting jaw dropping and
bombastically animated action sequences
with more mundane and lighthearted fare
purposefully that capture the chainsaw
man Ness for lack of a better term I was
worried I wouldn't see I mean that
sequence where it zooms in on Powers
chess only to further zoom in again into
something more absurd with Genji in the
background all pixelated just feels so
candid and full of the wackiness the
series is known for and as I'm sure many
of you have noticed or seen being
discussed online already the op of this
also features countless nods to Classic
films such as Reservoir Dogs The Texas
Chainsaw Massacre Pulp Fiction and No
Country for Old Men to name but a
fraction of the references crammed into
this op fitting as the author of
Chainsaw man himself Fujimoto is a
massive movie buff but how do I
personally determine the quality of a
series you might be asking well
typically I have a few indicators to
look out for with regards to an intro
chapter or in this case intro episode
there's a tremendous amount of heavy
lifting this section of the story is
required to shoulder what sort of
lifting is required well it depends
largely on the sort of story you're
trying to tell take attack and Titan for
example aot is a story whose strengths
reside in the dramatic grotesque and the
Mysterious and due to the attention span
of many readers this opening chapter
needed to be capable of communicating
those exact qualities while
simultaneously investing us into the
main cast themselves Hajime isigama
achieved this balance through the
character of Aaron Jaeger a character
whose entire being runs counter to the
status quo in this world and so by
getting to know him and his Ambitions we
gradually and most importantly naturally
learn about the broader world of Attack
on Titan its Mysteries and finally the
dramatic threat on the final few pages
and so keeping that in mind those chains
of men deliver a captivating opening
well let's have a look broadly speaking
the story of Chainsaw man explores the
life of her main character denji a down
in his luck orphan struggling to pay off
his father's debts as a freelance devil
Hunter for simplicity's sake devils are
this universe's monsters and he works on
this role alongside his little canine
chainsaw devil friend pochita the rules
of this world are relatively simple with
the only Nuance coming by way of
something that's called a contract an
agreement made specifically between a
devil and human resulting in the first
chapter depicting a fusion of denji and
his little devil dog pochita turning
denji effectively into a hybrid of a
human and devil before being discovered
by the mysterious makima offering denji
a dilemma die here as a devil by her
hand or work for her and her
government-funded devil Hunter agency
and that's the basic outline of the
first episode where Attack on Titan was
driven by its plot and mystery chainsaw
man at least in these opening chapters
or episodes is driven by its characters
in the same way Aaron Jaeger facilitates
natural chances to show why his series
was interesting so too does denji serve
his story only in a much more reactive
sense where Aaron in Attack on Titan was
inclined to drive the plot forward denji
by virtue of who he is sort of goes with
the flow while other much stronger
personalities joined The Fray later on
allowing the series to feel much more
like an ensemble cast despite it being
specifically about denji's Journey but
that's just the story front when I look
at an anime adaptation I also look for
ways this chosen medium has been used in
ways the manga did not have available to
bolster the themes and direction of the
story at hand I look for this because it
offers a greater utility to the anime
itself making use of the chosen medium
all the while enhancing The Source
material if done correctly and I think
these First episodes show signs of that
already there's a lot of atmospheric
ambient lighting that seems to correlate
and create contrast in following the
through line of the story or at least
denji's mood projecting Genji's fondness
from the past in bright colors with the
gritty Moody and Grim reality he finds
himself in living currently is a
strikingly effective contrast and not
something that was at fujimoto's
disposal in the manga with the message
and Mission set by pochita being to turn
his real world and circumstances into
the dreams he professed to have
resulting in one of the most metal and
badass Transformations I've seen in
quite some time the animated fight scene
depicting the birth of Chainsaw man was
a very well orchestrated if not slightly
understated from my taste personally
there's an interesting combination of 2D
and 3D effects work on display here that
really helped to capture the messy and
clumsy nature of this first outing in
the transformed State although for me
and what I was expecting I don't think
it captured the bloodbath intensity of
some of the panels from fujimoto's
original work during this section but of
course this is just a first episode and
there's still time however what's
interesting about this scene to me is
less the transformation and more so
makima's introduction action to the
series from the moment I saw this girl
while reading the Manga she scared me
stiff she's an oddly cam presence in
what is quite literally a world filled
with monsters introduced at the end of
the very first episode literally melting
through denju's more assertive side all
the way through to the vulnerable core
of his character she appears comforting
and exactly what Genji thinks he wants
however in reality she's offering him an
ultimatum one that if he chooses
incorrectly could result in his death
here and now as a devil this coupled
with the shadows and shrouding her
character The Authority she speaks with
and the fearless and disarming demeanor
she waltzes up to denji with makes for a
very interesting character to say the
least the likes of which are made to
make both us and Indie denji feels
smaller than and subservient too but
that's just the first episode the first
Arc Within These first couple of
episodes are largely centered around
introducing us to key recurring
characters in The Devil haunting agency
denji's join as well as the duties he
has therein the first of these key
characters that I've already touched on
is makima she seems to be a higher up in
this government-funded agency tasked to
take down Devils for society and is on
this weird power kick with denji I will
almost definitely touch on later
emphasis on touch next is Aki hayakawa
denji's colleague or should I say
Handler compared to denji and a certain
other character I'll touch on in just a
second he's quite stoic with a lot more
going on right beneath the surface we've
not yet seen much of he also acts as a
vehicle for which denji can reaffirm his
convictions to us as an audience his
Dynamic with hayakawa acts as a
convenient mechanism for us to learn
more about this world as denji unaware
of the broader details of his new Devil
powers and indeed the world's rules can
ask all the necessary questions for
which Aki can facilitate an answer in
the past I've praised fujimoto's
paneling and described it as funnier
than some of my favorite comedic mangas
ever and that's something I was very
concerned about when I saw the anime's
initial trailer what it looked utterly
spectacular and A Feast for the eyes if
ever there was one while all of that was
of course promised I was less convinced
about the comedy which as I learned upon
reading this series is a core component
that makes the experience of Chainsaw
man so special but but I've glossed over
makima and denji's initial meeting and I
want to emphasize that while the manga
was brilliant I thought the anime
offered its own Flair that enhanced or
at the very least reinforced the moment
substantially on a visual level the
direction is honestly terrific for this
scene and both voice actors play up
their roles exceptionally well Genji
specifically when he says he cannot feed
himself leading to a weirdly well
animated sequence where makima feeds him
udon similarly and in that vein I enjoy
how visually makima lifts guides denji
away from the shadows of his former life
and into the bright and vibrant new
world for him and us to explore as
pointed out moments prior denji's
current dream is to exist in the world
and have a decent standard of living and
in getting this the world is depicted in
an ethereal almost dreamlike glow at
least in contrast to where he once was
and this meaning with makima acts as the
core ignition point for this technique
to be employed throughout this season
lifting him out of the gutter the Sun
starts to rise as she hugs him and as
their day presses on and he realizes
what his new life is going to be the
reality of this world around denji grows
brighter and brighter with a nice amount
of Comedy thrown into boot however I
think this opening's most important
narrative component at least in terms of
pacing comes in episode 2 following this
sudden realization by denji that he's
already achieved his goal and so he
recognizes that his life isn't going to
be worth much if he's already achieved
his goal of getting off the streets and
eating relatively well he sees people
like hayakawa driven by retribution
makima driven by
oh
[Music]
this is however where I think I'm going
to run into some issues here with this
adaptation scenes like this while iconic
in the manga due to the nature of
reading offers a lot of interpretation
and subjectivity for each reader I've
seen similar things happen in the past
where a famous book might get adapted
and fans of the series will have gripes
with a lot of surface level choices made
because it doesn't map onto how they
interpreted a scene or a character and
that can really impact how a person
feels about a scene and I think this is
such an instance for me I don't think
they captured the impact of the innocent
quiet absurdity that was quote I wanna
touch poops which honestly is a shame
meme anime moments like this aren't
impossible to get right as seen with the
now famous quote okay moment from one
punch Man's first season delivered
perfectly but with that said it's not a
massive deal and I'm more interested in
how this adaptation can offer new
reasons to love this story for instance
the conviction denji delivers his boob
speech afterwards was I think better
than the manga presented stunningly as
the lewd posters in the background act
as the goal with which his hand grasps
at offering again a nice visual metaphor
to play into the strengths of the media
but yes this is denji's new goal my
friends and this is where a new
character called power comes screaming
into the story
to denjis Yang while also sharing so
many things in common with him and her
introductory story with the group is on
its face utterly silly with denji
effectively trying to win Powers favor
to touch her chest however what spawns
from this is oddly and surprisingly
brilliant however before I talk about
that and while I have an entire section
dedicated to the production of this
anime later I just have to talk about
tatsuki fujimoto's character designs
because they're absolutely outstanding
when one starts designing a character
one of the most important aspects to
keep in mind is how this design will
serve to communicate to a reader who
this character is just at a glance denji
as a character is quite unassuming and
simple and his character design reflects
that very reality Hajime isayama took a
very similar approach with Aaron Jaeger
in Attack on Titan by drawing him in a
rather unremarkable and almost
forgettable fashion the point of Aaron
Jaeger early on is to point out that he
isn't remarkable and the same is true
for chainsaw man's denji in this
instance furthermore and again like
Aaron Jaeger Genji transform state is
enhanced to look even more impressive
simply by comparison to his base form
think Magikarp and Gyarados Gyarados
looks impressive already but when you
look at Magikarp next to it suddenly it
looks all the more monstrous and where
Aaron in Attack on Titan enhances his
Titan form's intimidation Factor one
could say that chainsaw man utilizes and
leans into this very visual trick a lot
more effectively brandishing a meek and
shrinking posture wearing a large amount
of white with rounded almost quivering
shapes and lines used to convey his
softer Human Side tenji's physical form
stands in stark contrast with a violent
Jagged and exaggerated shapes that
caught this Comics pages in the blood of
its enemies in every sense of the word
this design is one built on the back of
contrasts contrasts that communicate a
distinct shift in how this character
engages with the world around him
whether it be exaggerated instances like
those in which he fully transforms or
even the Crooked Smiles he shares when
something more is on his mind denji is a
regular almost forgettable looking
person in the world when nothing is
driving him or threatening him however
when something does even a little bit he
starts to reveal a set of sharp and
potentially dangerous teeth perhaps
implying that right beneath this
unassuming facade lies the power of a
true devil furthermore and quite
ingeniously I very much love how denji
being ill-equipped to put on his own tie
for the uniform facilitates not only his
depiction as someone that doesn't come
from this world but also provides a nice
visual metaphor for a dog collar the
uniform given to him by makima and the
tie wrapped around his neck represents a
leash a noose and a new way of life all
at once someone like hayakawa on the
other hand is almost the exact opposite
and seems to be wound quite tight and I
think partly this is what makes his
Dynamic with denji so interesting while
dengie's outward appearance is
consistently messy hayakawa always has
his hair tied up purposefully all the
while he wears a much more complete dark
uniform symbolic of his Devotion to the
job he has and perhaps hint towards a
darker backstory driving him forwards
and finally let's talk about power the
character of power speaks to this
philosophy directly the moment we meet
power she is over the top loud and
Swinging her fist in the air a big
personality with an appearance that
communicates that very aspect of her
character through her clothes and devil
traits being much more obvious on her
than on dengie's character design
whether it be her disheveled hair half
tucked in shirt Jagged teeth horns or
her eyes bearing a striking resemblance
to that of a crosshairs on a gun power
comes across as a boisterous mischievous
and active character to team up with are
less driven and thus far comparatively
passive main character in denji creating
this wonderful kinetic push and pull
Dynamic which leads us nicely into the
second and really the first major arc of
this story the bat devil Arc episode 3 4
and part of 5 are where we finally begin
to get a handle on the main through line
of the story and while a shallow level
observation of this r Arc might lead you
to believe it's a simple Noble Quest a
young man undergoes to earn Powers favor
it is in fact a story about complicated
themes of manipulation trust and other
things in interviews Fujimoto the author
of Chainsaw man's manga has revealed
that a main inspiration behind the
character of power came from that of
other than South Park's very own Eric
Cartman
that is dude
and you could absolutely see that in her
introductory sequence she's chaotic
abrasive and most importantly active
making her a terrific addition to
denji's already reactive personality
creating moments for him to react to and
indeed for us to learn more about the
story screw you guys and getting him
this is what we understand and know
about power but in episode 3 following
power's introduction and subsequent
professional mistake both her and denji
begin to argue as makima Cuts them both
off immediately Power stops shouting and
listens
despite the wording of this being
slightly different to what I read in the
manga it is at least at this point in
the story The only indication that
something more is going on with makima
and absolutely put her on my watch list
while the rest of this story unfolded on
one hand she seems to be held in pretty
high regard by pretty much everyone
including Aki who we don't have any
reason not to trust at this point but on
the other hand she treats both denji and
power as if they were dogs and in
response to this supposed coercion once
power learns what denji wants she
leverages that so she can achieve her
ends power wants her cat back from this
devil holding it hostage and denji wants
the goods each individual has something
the other can potentially fulfill and
therein lies the motivation and dynamic
for this short arc's hijinks when I read
the story of one piece I loved it for
its depth of lore character and at times
profound introspection its accuracy when
dissecting The Human Condition through a
Cavalcade of warm and fiendish
characters with chainsaw man I love it
almost as much for what amounts to
practically the exact opposite reason in
this Arc and I think it's down to how in
a sense simple Fujimoto has decided to
keep his plot lines at least as we
understand them right now how many
points of view or groups are we
following in this story just one really
dengian power patrolling the area and
looking for her lost cat and thanks to
this Fujimoto is never really in a rush
to communicate anything to us if he
wants to show two colleagues sitting in
a bus with nothing to talk about he will
if he wants to show an awkward
interaction for the sake of a joke he
will more than happily sacrifice many
pages or in this case seconds or minutes
of an anime to bring that Vision to life
and due to this the result isn't
something you need to study feverishly
there's rarely ever a single moment
where you're challenged with a massive
Exposition dump and think I sure hope I
hold on to all of this information and
so chainsaw man because of its approach
makes exceptional use of space
expression character acting voice acting
and music which in turn enhances the
humor drama and ultimately the horror
element of this story helped
tremendously by facilitating some great
character-defining moments for denji
where he decides to show his desire to
protect people and other moments where
he chooses to be more Reckless and while
the fight is great it's the latter part
of that which makes this story Blossom
for me particularly when it comes to
power and denji's relationship and not
to mention animation if we rewind back a
bit this Series has some tremendous
animation to speak on but some of the
most understated moments like two
individuals hanging out and exploring
each other's minds all the while being
surrounded by a bunch of Illuminating
vending machines bathing them in an
ambient glow offering a spectacular
atmospheric tone furthermore I hope
folks notice that while denji is
pursuing his dreams the world around him
is Fantastical and dreamlike however
when he goes farther away from that
reality his world becomes darker again
muted lifeless exemplified through Power
dragging denji away from his new world
in dengue's mind he's moving closer to
his goal of touching power's chest but
in reality and Visually it's
communicated that he's moving farther
away to his conspired death reflected in
the muting of the colors and light as he
approaches the bat Devil's Hideout and I
just love when shows like this succeed
in this sort of way
action where denji proves the power that
he's someone worthy of further
consideration unlike denji power is
categorized by everyone including
herself as someone very different to
dingy and other humans countless times
she points out emotional problems she
sees with the way denji and other humans
Express themselves this cold way of
seeing the world is chalked up to her
being a fiend by others and even us
until we see her internal feelings
concerning her beloved cat having lured
an ambush denji into this bat Devil's
Lair to sacrifice him and rescue her cat
she herself gets double-cross and in the
process eat and while denji finds new
reserves of boob inspired strength we as
an audience dive deep into who she is as
a character and we learn that while she
is quite disconnected she is capable of
feeling an appreciation and fondness for
something more than her own well-being
furthermore having now seen the
animation for the bat devil vs chainsaw
man I have to say that I thought it felt
a lot more frantic and intense in the
manga this isn't to suggest of course
that there's not something to enjoy here
there's of course some great effects
work and composition the 2D animation
sequences are brilliant with a fantastic
final Blow from denji and personally I
enjoyed this fight though I think that
in this instance the 3D elements stand
out in my mind as the weakest part
however I do like how they handled the
transition from power's imagination of
death to her eventual Rescue by denji
the ambient noise of the city really
elevates Genji's and her reaction
afterwards helping to make the subtle
attack from the subsequent leech devil
all the more surprising and impactful
furthermore the animation and direction
for the sequence feels League stronger
than the former the way the smoke
effects Cloud our screen the way the
blood sloshes up beneath denji's feet as
he scrambles and rushes his opponent
almost falling over with his eagerness
to do so it's a wonderfully kinetic
scene that's Amplified even further by
denju's voice as he delivers the
monologue for the final attack having
only seen this series Once and read it
only once this fight scene due to the
treatment it's received in this series
has been offered a chance to stand as
one of the best fight scenes in this
story Mickey had all the more memorable
it's spectacular with the cutoff by
hayakawa's Fox devil made all the more
emphatic as a result and even if we put
the action aside I love the attention
the series gives to the finer details
like hayakawa turning off his alarm in a
controlled manner how he slowly opens
his balcony door pictured from afar and
makes his coffee in the morning all of
these choices help not only to create a
distinct atmosphere but to tell us
something about hayakawa himself without
interfering with the script of the
original series he's a creature of habit
order and Duty building up the perfect
party for power to crash and terrorize
with her presence I will say however
while humorous this direction does feel
different to the manga in tone and I
think that's been discussed online quite
a bit where the manga felt a lot more
silly and impulsive this feels a lot
more measured and muted in tone I mean
whether intentional or not I thought it
worth mentioning at this moment before I
dive into what is many and my personal
favorite part of this first season a
sequence I am going to be calling
henceforth A Tale of Two gropes or at
least I would call it this if it for
some bizarre reason wasn't split in two
to some this might be a non-issue but
for me this split up the two best
contrasting scenes in the manga dengie's
encounter with power and subsequent
encounter with makima it makes for a
good Cliffhanger to end an episode on
but in my opinion splits the two scenes
that work together the best in the
series
as I mentioned towards the beginning of
this review denji comes from a life of
virtually nothing and as if like a stray
dog picked up by makima's Animal Control
he quickly tries to find a goal to latch
onto a dream to help him feel like part
of the group like part of the team to
feel like his life is worthwhile for his
little dog's sacrifice and while this
initial motivation is played for Laughs
on a number of occasions that by the way
worked to great effect surprisingly it's
denji's reaction to his reaching of this
goal that's quite interesting in the
anime I like how the direction
emphasizes how the magic and wonder of
the experience evaporates away following
the first grope on power something isn't
right and the direction of the scene
visually reflects this the angle is flat
and lifeless the sound design is
uninspired and empty the expression on
dengue's face says it all this isn't
what he expected and the reason I would
have liked for these scenes to have
followed each other would be to
emphasize their intentional contrast
when we switch scenes to makima's
meeting with denji at the top of the
following episode the muted direction
from Power scene is flipped on its head
once makima turns off the heat the fuzzy
shaky camera point of view with soft
Edge lighting It's a Wonderful touch to
add a sense of intimacy to the occasion
suddenly we can observe the dust
floating in the air like this moment in
time is significant and we need to
breathe it all in the music itself
serves to enhance the illusion of what's
going on also if you're wearing
headphones the notes float from one ear
to the other independent of each other
in a certain Rhythm almost like we are
in this moment with denji and our senses
have been dulled or compromised it's
feels almost dreamlike again however
this time in a way that we've not yet
seen so intense Amplified by the
outstanding voice work from akima's
voice actor her matter of fact way of
speaking slowly and seductively crawls
to a whisper until the music and her
voice stops and gives way to the Grove
depicted during a short Dolly Zoom to
further give way to that moment itself
we exist in this moment for a brief
interlude with the only audio noticeable
coming from denji's hand on her fabric
almost like nothing else in the world
exists in this moment it's a great scene
that plays the strengths of the medium
and as we eventually leave this moment
and Retreat back to normality the audio
from the clock and eventually the
ambient noise of the office returns to
the scene in addition to that a nice
visual metaphor that wasn't apparent in
the manga between power and mocking
machines was the use of real and
artificial light to emphasize the
difference between the two experiences
Powers offering was held under harsh
artificial bathroom light to perhaps
emphasize how cold and artificial this
encounter was while makimas was lit with
the warm Hues of the Setting Sun and
most importantly there's a change in
physical level that reflects that
emotional reality where denji stood
above power during their scene in
bakimas It's the exact opposite she
looms over his shoulder standing next to
him at first while he sits and when he
falls to the floor this divide in how
they perceive each other is embellished
and emphasized makima is powerful and in
control treating denji like a dog she's
training and just like with any new
puppy you reward good behavior with
treats that way they understand Who the
Master truly is in response to this
interaction with power it was honest and
platonic through their combined journey
in this Arc they form a much more
tangible and mutually beneficial
relationship with makimas she further
manipulates denji into accepting a
tremendously dangerous mission to find
an apprehend a villain that's eluded her
and her Agency for years
the gun devil ladies and gentlemen this
is our main narrative through line
The Eternity devil before we talk about
the story itself I want to talk firstly
about something I read in preparation
for this review a One-Shot manga
entitled look back released in 2021 by
tatsuki Fujimoto himself and within this
it drew my attention to something
fujimura does tremendously well
something I noticed in that one shot and
in this very Arc numerous times that
being a shocking and sudden Twist of
events sometimes in storytelling there's
an indication that something big will
happen soon where the author alludes to
something approaching on the horizon
subtly or explicitly in any case this
can be compared to Hitchcock's famous
bomb under the table narrative technique
where one to varying degrees lets the
readers know there's a metaphorical bomb
under the table turning a given scene
into a great mechanism for building
tension however as it happens Fujimoto
foregoes such warnings in favor of
something that will completely take you
by surprise in this Arc Fujimoto begins
to show us a flashback of a family it's
filled with enough detail and its very
own narrative to allow it to stand on
its own two feet we follow the story
eagerly awaiting a resolution that's
being built up to and then
we're reminded that this was a story
detailing the gun Devil's origin
impressing unto us in a much more
visceral fashion just how sudden and
devastating This Disaster was and I
think what I love about this technique
is that it's so versatile Fujimoto uses
this very technique in look back to
create a powerful sense of loss and
emotional Outburst right here in this
Arc he uses it to impress upon us the
severity of the occasion however right
now we have one goal find the gun devil
and they have a means to do so too
following the attack that took place
wiping out millions of people across the
world on behalf of the gun devil certain
parts of the gun devil have been found
in different bodies of different devils
and once enough parts are gathered they
start to be drawn to the gun devil
itself simple effective and within that
framework there's tons of flexibility so
how does Fujimoto proceed by setting up
a narrative technique I adore in
long-running TV shows and movies the
bottle episode in these situations the
director or in this case author takes
the established cast and places them
into a finite space for the majority
Authority or the entire duration of the
story I love this because we no longer
need context clues or establishing shots
instead we can focus on continuous
scenes filled with opportunities for
interesting character retrospectives and
in the case of Chainsaw man gags this
was the section I was most interested in
to see how they'd adapted within a manga
The Familiar inbox setting of a series
of rooms and doors can be striking and
lend well to the medium at hand there's
a tremendous amount of perspective on
offer there but an animation you need to
oftentimes use different techniques
specific to the medium to not look super
boring Furthermore with his approach
Fujimoto leaned heavily on the strengths
of the manga media itself to help
communicate his jokes I mean some of
these gags or sequences look as though
they're straight out of a comic strip in
some instances this is of course to the
strength of the manga as someone that
studies film and art for a living the
concept of a bottle episode has always
fascinated me with how when done well
they can be massively engaging offering
up tons of tension as a result and while
I don't think this adaptation did
anything incorrect or super wrong I do
think the anime struggled to compensate
for that loss of strength otherwise seen
in the manga in animation as I've
pointed out numerous times in this
review color is a massive strength it
has however this entire episode is
bathed in these flat yellow tones these
can of course be evocative of different
films or horror stories in the genre but
with all the time we spend here it only
ends up feeling more and more wooden
note than the comparatively colorless
manga somehow to me this isn't of course
to suggest that this didn't offer
anything noteworthy or great to enjoy
following the trail of the gun devil
denji Aki power and three new characters
Ximena kobenai and arai following the
slaughter of a single weird looking
devil in the building find themselves
trapped on the eighth floor they can't
go up or down the stairs they can't go
through the ceilings and the windows all
lead back to the eighth floor it's like
they're stuck in their own little
parallel universe or Wormhole Dimension
I love this this is the third Arc of
this series and while each Arc ends with
a big battle between chainsaw and denji
and insert monster here each encounter
feels so very different from each other
the first one in the introductory arc
facilitates our introduction to the
world and its rules the second one with
the bat Devils served to introduce us to
different characters and this one very
much shows us how the chainsaw devil
Powers work in Greater detail all the
while allowing us to form much more
deeper connections to the likes of Aki
whose backstory we see himeno who
provides the stakes for denji in this
act with a kiss to motivate him or power
Who provided me with more Betty laughs
than any other manga I've read in the
past
power's now famous plan to become Prime
Minister never misses its Mark for me
it's the right level of absurdist humor
meeting dire circumstances that tickle
me in a way only Power I'm both Cartman
can muster
denji falling asleep in the bed was a
gag that I loved in the manga and
thought translated over to the anime
really well the way the camera
constantly switches between hayakawa and
denji as he slowly drifts to sleep gets
me every time and is very similar to the
manga's portrayal of the events funnily
enough with how it's framed something I
did notice while this series was on the
air was just how many folks ended up
hating kobeni and her frankly realistic
reaction to the situation at hand I
think moments like this not only show
how incredible her voice actor is at
performing but on a narrative level
helps to create moments of Courage that
feel all the more powerful down the line
as a result of this initial cowardice
contrast is King folks and people are
complicated and messy so try to keep
that in mind all of that aside however
something I thought this section of the
anime did rather well was communicate
the horror element of the series perhaps
better than any other episode so far the
sheer dread and drama that builds up to
Aki being stabbed by kobeni is feverish
and a stand doubt moment in the series
now for me and not to mention I thought
it was more striking than it was in the
manga with denji's descent into the
bowels of the devil itself also
receiving similar focus and I think
that's one of this adaptation's biggest
strengths it can on occasion fail to
live up to some aspects of the manga but
in others it offers extra focus and Care
on lesser beloved moments such that they
can then in turn become someone else's
favorite moment in other words it's an
entirely different and unique experience
and in my opinion both are worthy of
your time and attention with that said
the bloody Carnage in the manga is once
again enhanced by the gruesome barbarism
of this scene there's so much thrashing
pulsating and impressive movement on
display enhanced by the sound design and
the shrieking cackles of denji's voice
actor however I'd be lying if I said
that this was the part of the arc people
remember or that I have stuck in my head
please drink responsibly like the prior
Arc the conflict wasn't the focus but
instead the rewards and resolutions
following the demonstration Hime know
and the rest of the group go out for
drinks together in celebration makima is
supposed to attend this get-together and
she does so drinking a hell of a lot
more than pretty much anyone else at the
table however something happens kimano
is drunk she promised dengia tonkus and
what denji gets is not that instead
fujimota decides to draw one of the most
legendary panels I've ever seen ladies
and gentlemen behold art is meant to
make you feel something and that
something can be anger Joy lust or
really anything
and this piece this piece right here
that you're looking at that I'm making
you look at for longer than you might be
comfortable with this made me feel
something deep in my stomach I only wish
I could say the same for the anime
instead of the nostalgic nausea I'd
normally feel wash over me with this
scene the anime's interpretation only
left me with disappointment and while
while disappointing for now there is a
silver lining that we can all hang on to
as a collective fan of high art the
issue at hand here is that unlike manga
which depicts every disgusting element
of the vomit in my new detail the anime
for reasons I can only assume are
censorship decided to pixelate the
entire fantastic event taking place in
denji's mouth here does this suck the
joy out of the scene absolutely but do
we have the digital release of this
series to look forward to that I suspect
won't have the tasteless censorship for
us to endure the answer is yes following
this event himino takes denji back to
her place where he wakes up
foreign
I plan to talk about this episode in
detail later in the video when
discussing the development and behind
the scenes aspects of the season but I
have to gush for a second because
episode 8 is on another level when it
comes to this season's quality and
that's not to suggest that this season's
quality is necessarily low the effort
and ambition across the board is evident
for all to see but this episode and
really this scene itself is astonishing
so intimately depicted as himino moves
around her apartment to get ready if
there's any scene that was enhanced by
the anime's adaptation it's this one
it's breathtakingly impressive a master
class in character acting and both some
truly inspired animation choices one
that stood out to me is the POV shaky
cameras hemino approaches denji on the
bed it's his point of view we're seeing
and you can really feel that it offers a
remarkably unique look while increasing
the level of intimacy of this otherwise
casual encounter there's just so much
movement and creativity and narratively
this all serves the purpose of showing
us where Genji's mind is at is he
looking to hold out for makima does he
feel guilty well will it matter
by the time I finish reading this Arc I
felt myself thinking this more so than
any other story I've read feels like a
brilliant and Natural Evolution of the
tropes established by one piece and
before then Dragon Ball this feels like
something entirely fresh and new and I
don't really understand how best else to
express that feeling this is of course
not to say that this story is remotely
like any of these properties however the
strengths that make these stories stand
out for me I feel were Inspirations for
chainsaw men tatsuki fujimono is the
youngest mangaka I've ever covered on
this channel and in addition to that the
only Creator I've ever covered that's
younger than me at 30 years of age he
comes from the generation of children
that grew up with stories like one piece
of Naruto and he says as much the choice
to have this seismic shift and narrative
occur at this time following this
intimate event in this way it just feels
exceedingly refreshing and when I was
reading the manga for the first time I
audibly gasped when I saw this reveal
it's remarkable what this Young author
is able to pull off at this stage of his
career and just makes me very excited to
see what more he can come up with and
who he can Inspire in the future the
katana devil alright so now we arrive at
The Last Arc of this season and
fittingly it's the longest stretched
across the runtime of about four and a
half episodes and with the conclusion of
the Last Arc being makima meeting an
intimate end courtesy of a gun
oh wait
well then with this narrative decision
Fujimoto is keeping us off balance he's
got on the record and pointed out that
he likes being able to write stories
that keep you on your toes stories that
keep you off balance and unsure as to
what exactly is around the next corner
he has makima shot denji conflicted and
guilty but determined to be with her in
another scene and so with that we as an
audience are thinking about how the bad
news of makima's demise will impact
Genji and his motivation and then
something even more substantial happens
we've gotten hints about this particular
angle towards the end of The Last Arc
but every villain or devil that denji in
the corporation he fights for faces off
against seems to have the same
underlying Mission driving them in the
direction of denji to steal his heart
and right as makima was taken out by
those Yakuza thugs denji gets shot in
the face by another member of this unit
in the middle of a restaurant with Aki
power and himino present something I've
noticed that this series does is that
when one episode ends the next episode
and the team that created that episode
will represent to the closing moments
from the previous episode in their own
way it adds a different atmosphere
oftentimes showing a different point of
view and helps to transition us in a
natural way from one scene to another
contrasting moment the beginning of
episode 9 offers such a scene where
episode 8 closed in a harrowing
emotional and beautiful fashion episode
9 offers a much more gradual transition
to denji's interjection to the battle as
chainsaw man it's surprisingly effective
and I haven't seen any anime that I've
covered employee such approaches
everything about this scene feels
desperate out of nowhere himino is down
for the count power is hamstrung trying
to help her stay alive by managing her
blood supply denji is out cold from
being shot in the face and Aki is
struggling to stay alive against this
new enemy it's a frantic and desperate
scramble to regain the upper hand with
Aki actually getting just that in the
end but thanks to this new character
Beth victory in Advantage he struggled
to achieve is robbed from him and when I
was first digesting this material my
heart was racing I mean sincerely you
feel that in the desperation of everyone
involved on the side of denji
particularly through the likes of Aki
whipping out his sword without regard
for the very consequences we learned of
in the prior Arc and most impactfully
himino this is once again a story of
contrast in the same way the designs
betray and work to complement the
actions and personalities of these
characters himino's self the sacrifice
of herself to prolong the life of the
person she loves and Aki is contrast
starkly by the devil she enlists the
help of this beautifully altruistic
action is set alongside the utterly
terrifying and grotesque looking ghost
of hers once she gives her body up for
it truly the stuff of nightmares
[Music]
last time I said that this girl was
scary now I am saying that this girl
terrifies me to my core systematically
and in retaliation to the Yakuza that
attacked her and her agency she
sacrifices person after person atop this
weird Monastery or Shrine area and in
doing so turns a ton of Yakuza targets
into popped blood balloons remotely from
God knows how far away this feels like
the most otherworldly god-like power
we've seen in this series and makima's
control and crushing of her enemies from
afire was fittingly abrupt and cool
although not particularly flashy and I
thought that was a bit weird it felt as
though what we saw in the trailer was I
don't know a lot more interesting and
dynamic that said the music and audio
for this section is quite compelling for
the moment that it's in leveraging that
aspect of the production to help Elevate
The Source material and it works well
enough and unfortunately in the same
vein I didn't think that the fight with
katana man was as impressive as I was
hoping for either the moment where he
cuts down in half felt as though it
didn't hit the dramatic highs of the
manga that moment offered perhaps my
expectations were misplaced or maybe I
didn't Vibe with the director in this
instance either way it's a little
upsetting the conflict on the ground
with denji and what's left of his team
is brought to a swift resolution as this
weird kid and Katana man make their
strategic Retreat I'll only touch on
this for a moment but I have to say
something here because apparently I'm a
massive SIM for fujimoto's layouts look
at how stupidly easy it is to read this
layout look how naturally our eyes
follow this page with kobani on the
sixth and seventh pages of chapter 28.
look at how each panel guides your eyes
to the next one in the sequence
effortlessly creating this sense of
movement without movement at all this is
the stuff I live for and whoever adapted
this moment seems to agree as this
attack to save chainsaw man from kobani
received the most attention in Flash in
this episode I think it looks terrific
and that's where this commentary on the
adaptation would normally end but unlike
the manga after this episode's
conclusion I couldn't help but feel that
the last scene outshone every other in
the episode to a substantial degree and
given that makima's control scene was
not only pivotal to the episode as a
whole but honestly might be the most
important reveal in the entire season
and it just didn't feel like it was
given the attention I thought it
deserved I mean it's the mask off moment
for the character and at least compared
to what was promised in the trailers the
anime's adaptation feels extremely safe
and almost boring compared to what was
promised this isn't of course to suggest
the scene is bad this is chainsaw man
after all no amount of uninspired
framing could suck the joy out of it
completely I mean the writing and setup
alone is going to allow folks to love
this moment for what it is and find it
shocking but the way it's framed while
perfectly fine and adequate I felt could
have used a little more Flair with that
said kobani's scene offered her a nice
little bit of redemption after her
championing denji's death mirror
episodes ago I just would have preferred
if that attention went little more
elsewhere but I suppose it's a nitpick
speaking on akihayakawa for just a
moment within both this Arc and the next
one he acts as the heartbeat or emotion
of the story speaking on this Arc
specifically particularly following the
initial fight with katana man despite
almost losing his life he focuses
instead on what he's lost which quite
elegantly highlights what makes his
character a wonderful contrast with the
likes of denji again causing denji
himself to feel that discrepancy between
him and Aki also however in reality
denji 2 has something Aki should want
that is to live denji is happy with his
lot in life and numerous times he
alludes to this reality in the story
It's a Wonderful powerful feeling for a
character to have he's happy that he's
alive every single day whereas a large
part of Aki's story concerns him being
tortured by his decisions as he
tirelessly marches like a soldier day in
day out towards his death in other words
denji seems to be willing to do anything
to maintain the best life he can
possible where whereas Aki seems to be
tirelessly in search of his way out in
pursuit of his own goal within this r s
Arc there's a great emphasis on
flashbacks exploring the first meaning
and budding friendships with himino that
said all of this has been quite
emotionally heavy in action-packed so
next up is probably my favorite part of
this particular Arc the training video
arc now that it's become known the gun
devil is after denji's heart for some
yet unknown reasons makima has seen it
necessary to enroll both power and deji
himself into training to hone their
respective abilities and Powers it also
acts as a nice tune-up for everyone
reading along to see what makes each of
these characters take physically and
somewhat emotionally prior to accepting
them as pupils or play things as he
calls them later on this rather
intimidating individual asks power and
denji a set of questions probing their
individual morality the initial fight
itself between kishibe and the combined
efforts of dengian power is supremely
ambitious and well executed although
quite short the storyboard swoops across
the area and has so much fun doing so
before being brought to an abrupt end as
swiftly as it began the animation is
spectacular and in my opinion again
hides that very instant from the manga
which it's based narratively however
this is an interesting scene too for
upon a moment's notice the teamwork
between the two is apparent and while
power matching forward without
hesitation can be chalked up to her
fiend status and really her character in
general denji's zero hesitation seems
somewhat chilling to me which again
makes me think back to the metaphor
that's constantly being thrown around to
describe what denji is to both makima
and her agency that he's akin to a dog
dogs at least to me aren't Born Killers
but they can be trained to be and denji
seems to have lived a life that has
sculpted him into this person or makima
is slowly turning him into someone that
cannot value human life like akikan who
is by the way someone we have now
learned has lost the power to wield his
Fox spirit in battle due to how Reckless
he was being in the battle with katana
man signifying perhaps that even a
literal canine Spirit couldn't
comfortably do what the devil agency
expects Aki to do this is an agency that
sees their employees as necessary and
probable collateral damage Aki
specifically demonstrates this with
their offer to allow him to wield a new
Devil a devil that can see into the
future one that says he Aki is going to
die in the worst possible way and due to
this we'll give him some of his power in
exchange for a front row seat to his own
death how screwed up is that all that
depressing stuff aside the training with
power and denji is super fun dozens and
dozens of fail attacks on this special
division leader later and the team of
dengue and power are after trying
everything that came to them naturally
and in a cute bit of character
collaboration they jointly come up with
a plan to instead and I quote fight him
using our minds with denji's response to
this idea being like how cool would it
be if we could fight like one of those
brainy guys in manga and stuff this my
friends is the caliber of strategic
introspection we're seeing now so
naturally I wasn't expecting much but
the plan that they do eventually come up
with was actually kinda brilliant
[Music]
overall despite this operation ending in
a big fat loss this dude gives them
props for their efforts this effort
being their best to date however it does
end with this scary dude loving them
into a false sense of security before
teaching them yet again another lesson
which again I could choose to read as
another indirect suggestion to denji
that he shouldn't trust makima the
training continues until eventually
denji shows his gratitude to him and
interestingly this is the last lesson
that this individual teaches denji who
once he shows his teacher gratitude
entices him to never accept him as a
pupil ever again he only trained denji
because he thought he was inhuman but in
this moment it now doesn't seem to be
the case and he reveals this decision to
step away from denji and power's
training in an honestly unsettling scene
between himself and makima the subject
matter within this scene is that of him
questioning makima's allegiance to the
agency with some wonderful imagery
depicting how untrusting and distant she
feels to him ending on an uncomfortable
close-up of makima's face makima herself
has demonstrated a fascination with
power and she's demonstrated that she
herself is capable of some truly
horrific acts this dude asks makima in
this scene if she is on human Humanity's
side and perhaps and this could be a
stretch but perhaps he's asking her this
because she herself isn't human and the
only reason I wonder this is because
this individual this person that was
training denji stopped training denji
when he felt that Humanity emerged from
him he couldn't treat another human like
the way that he's been treating dinging
and perhaps in this instance he's
finding it difficult to trust makima
because she herself isn't a human or at
the very least isn't showing human
Tendencies perhaps makima herself has
her own ulterior motives concerning
influence and subjugation in the same
way she wants to manipulate denji like a
dog it seems like particularly in the
scene after this where she talks
directly with the Yakuza themselves she
tells us as readers more about herself
and her value system she says and I
quote your necessary evil is just an
excuse to justify your own crimes those
excuses are unnecessary to society which
tells me that she's doing everything
because she believes it's the best for
society that's a real totalitarian way
of looking at the situation when you you
ignore the context of the scene somewhat
and extrapolate it out into a personal
belief of hers it made me wonder what
she might actually be capable of as she
hands over a bag filled with the eyes of
the yakuza's family members perhaps
innocent family members it makes me
wonder how many eyes she has on the rest
of the world pun definitely intended or
maybe Fujimoto is totally screwing with
me and this is exactly what he wants me
to think I don't know but I digress
everything that's taken place in this
Arc from the initial Onslaught by the
yakuzenkatana man to the counter-attack
by makima to dengian power engaging in
training to makima pushing the Yakuza
into a corner all culminates in one
final battle between this sect of the
Yakuza versus this new special division
in the devil Hunter agency one that
begins is the new division infiltrates
this building during this section we as
an audience are introduced to a host of
new characters including the likes of
the violence Fiend The Spider devil
which looks horrifying and I'm not even
scared of spiders the shark fiend who
let me tell you gets very good in the
next Arc and finally the angel devil a
mysterious and unique devil that isn't
hostile towards humans one that if you
come into contact with them will shorten
your lifespan Aki takes the charge with
this particular group's infiltrating of
the thick zombie blockade there are of
course the instances where Aki
demonstrates his lack of consideration
towards his own well-being with him
coming concerningly close to the angel
devil however that's not the aspect of
this encounter I find interesting it's
instead the description that this is a
unique type of devil that isn't hostile
towards humans Aki vs ghost devil the
first interesting ruffle to show itself
upon the initial insurgence operations
comes by way of hayakawa's both literal
and metaphorical confrontation with a
ghost from the past the very ghost devil
that himino will did for the benefit of
him is now the one he needs to overcome
and take down and it's here I find
myself needing to remind myself of why
hayakawa is important to the story to
ground it while the story of Chainsaw
man itself through the likes of denji
power and makima paint a rather
nonchalant in human or silly story Aki
is also there to represent what's at
stake the love humans share for each
other the humanity of this world with
the very message himino leaves behind
for him to read cutting not only to the
core of his story but further
reinforcing what this line of work and
perhaps world is forcing him to be a
Fearless killing machine with his zero
fear approach literally granting him the
ability to slay this devil standing in
his way this is all to say that Aki is
perhaps one of the best handled
characters I've seen in the story and
one I have a door to follow throughout
so far
denji vs Katana man as power
goes off to do her thing Genji vs Katana
man round two gets underway but honestly
despite this being the final big fight
of the season I honestly have mixed
feelings on how it's portrayed and on
one hand I can see a lot of movement and
I did very much enjoy the scene in the
train but on the other hand outside of
the train scene which felt like an
adequate adaptation to the manga Source
material the fight itself felt to me
like it was I don't know lacking
identity lacking intensity and maybe
even personality and for a series like
chainsaw man that oozes silent
personality for this specific criticism
to be laid at the feet of this franchise
on what should be its climactic episode
is I don't know a little telling and I'm
gonna get into that a little bit more
with behind the scenes stuff later but
Dakota long story short it sort of felt
in many ways like it was any other fight
scene from the series lacking in any
meaningful or interesting art direction
to help it stand out but that's not the
same that nothing of node or interest
occurs within there's plenty and in my
mind less could be more with this fight
specifically when we've already sort of
seen some of this already with this
being the first rematch of the series so
to speak for Genji to deal with it
should go without saying that the panel
layouts work supremely effectively and
not only conveying the action moment to
moment but also the narrative when it
rears its head across the bout quote a
beast should never trust a hunter is
such an instance of this occurring this
particular phrase that denji recalls
from his training are acts for the
impetus behind his decisive winning blow
luring Katana man into a false sense of
security seizing his chance to use his
chainsaw powers in a way that we've not
yet seen with the way the anime composes
its shots much like the panels from the
manga section help to effectively
conceal the surprise for us to discover
on her own there's plenty of
introspective and human moments from
Katana man towards the start of this
battle however by the end he's used in a
way that I didn't see coming
following their respective fights denjin
hayakawa reconvened by the train tracks
in a surprisingly sweet moment of
connection they both get to share in a
moment of admittedly immature but much
needed humanity and therapy if you can
even call it that taking turns to kick
Katana man in the nuts for what he's
done to them both over the course of
this Arc Fujimoto also makes a subtle
nod to the Requiem scene in Hunter
Hunter only instead of a murder
Orchestra we have a Requiem composed
with the screams brought on by nutshots
truly it's a work of art and that just
about brings us to the conclusion of
this season and while I've largely had
praise for this adaptation the behind
the scenes demonstrates a very different
story one that requires a lot of nuance
to tell and an ability to separate the
final product from the reality of the
situation at hand during its development
and when I finished telling you all the
information I can about it my hope is
that by the end you can come away with a
different outlook on this season of
Chainsaw man because right now I want to
emphasize just how much of a miracle the
quality of this series truly was and how
much potential was lost as a result so
let's talk some behind the scenes
[Music]
user of the Chainsaw man anime was a
fascinating thing to take in as it
happened to be released right off the
back of me finishing my very first
read-through of the manga Fujimoto is a
weird mangaka in the best kind of way
and that disorientating chaos is one of
the most defining and appealing aspects
of his work and so for this teaser's
direction to be so cam grounded and well
Moody was fascinating and I was
interested to learn about how this came
to be studio mappa is a divisive name
whether it be because of personal
feelings on their anime or simply their
long-standing history of terrible
working conditions and so with a huge
name like chainsaw man attached to them
it was quite the surprise to learn that
they forewent any meddling production
committee to fund this themselves with
full creative control allowing them to
set their own pre-production schedule to
at least attempt to facilitate one man's
ambitious ideas for this project and
that man was Ryo Nakayama at only 32
years old it's a remarkably young age to
helm an entire series let alone one as
renowned as this it came about thanks to
mappa producer keske sashimo who
approached during nakayama's directorial
efforts in Jiu Jitsu kaizen's 19th
episode Nakayama is a talented animator
in his own right and with tsashimo being
a huge animation geek he was aware of
his talent for robust animation both in
terms of action and character along with
a number of interesting ventures in the
director's seat alongside this Nakayama
has a lot of talented friends an
invaluable asset for a series director
to have by the way and one that was
absolutely taken advantage of many times
throughout this production however the
core belief that Nakayama has echoed
throughout countless interviews at this
point is that this anime must not feel
like an anime and as a huge fan of
Fujimoto Nakayama strongly believes that
his work is completely Inseparable from
the movies that inspired them and so
this adaptation must feel like live
action Cinema from the absence of any
stylized colors to Banning anime
expressions like exaggerated sweat drops
and intentionally hiring newer actors to
avoid traditional performances Nakayama
has done everything in his power to make
this feel like animated live action and
seldom anything else this has been quite
the divisive approach and it's easy to
see why fujimoto's work while certainly
inspired by Cinema particularly in its
drama often sees its action and comedy
sway back and forth between moments of
world expressionism and Larger than Life
spreads with covers that display a lot
of vibrant and stylish Color Work none
of this is found in nakayama's chainsaw
man by Design instead translating these
into set pieces that wouldn't be out of
place in Western Cinema as a result the
anime hasn't been hugely popular among
Japanese fans with a widespread petition
being formed encouraging mappa to remake
it with another director Nakayama and
many other staff have unfortunately been
faced with exceptional vitriol on social
media and when one of the chief
animation supervisors off-handedly
tweeted that safe adaptations are boring
it caused enough of a storm that as
punishment the studio stripped his
credit down from Chief to regular
supervisor for his debut episode if
there's one thing I hope is clear
throughout this video however it's that
I really do enjoy this adaptation but it
does have its issues and I think there's
legitimate criticism worth listening to
this grounded cinematic approach does
wonders for shows in some areas while
coming at the cost of successes in
others but if one thing Rings true it's
that when nakayama's vision is put into
the hands of strong individual directors
real magic happens episode 4 is Far and
Away the most exhilarating
action-oriented episode in the series
and it comes from tatsuya yoshihara
someone many of you will know as the
passionate series director of Black
Clover and while that series was
famously married by an horrific
production environment yoshihara's
passion and talent for incredible action
always Shone through his relationship
with Nakayama was forged there and
resulted in his presence on the chainsaw
man adaptation as the series action
director in spite of this role and
frankly he admitted to not contributing
much anyway the moment he steps into the
director's chair he does away with
nakayama's rules of grounded action and
expression and instead shows denji at
his most wild both in Israel reactions
and the way he slings himself around the
screen in a larger than life and
unrestrained Manner and yet he still
brings it back to earth when needed and
delivers wonderful comedy chops in its
second half in a way that Nails
fujimoto's impeccable comedic paneling
likewise episode 8 as I mentioned
earlier in the review is an absolute
Masterpiece from shotagosho zono who
elevates the series's core foundations
its first half alone is a master class
in realistic character animation with a
board that oftentimes feels distant and
bordering and voyeuristic conveying the
depth of the environment while letting
its characters interact with it in a way
seldom found an anime at the same time
there are an abundance of ambitious POV
shots that although not executed
perfectly offer a unique and dynamic
approach to navigating its setting with
a near total absence of music for its
entire first half it relies solely on
diegetic sound and character
performances to weave itself into such a
delicate piece of animation and it all
comes together so damn well despite
feeling like a footnote in an already a
nominal episode its action in its second
half is weighty and impactful and
Carries all the necessary drama for what
is one of the most pivotal moments of
the season on the flip side there are
also episodes that didn't quite land and
concerningly they came directly from
Nakayama episode 7 almost feels like a
different show with how straightforward
its storyboard is and how poorly its
pivotal comedic moments Land episode 1
in 12's action lacks any real identity
and doesn't land with a gravitas you
would expect from a debut and finale
often a series director's episodes are
ones to look forward to the ones that
showcase the adaptation's vision at its
finest and yet they're arguably the
weakest by quite some margin it opens up
a curious question as to whether
nakayama's comparatively lesser outings
as an episode director are because of
his workload or inexperience and if that
inexperience and over ambition as a
series director is what led to a
schedule that ultimately began to
crumble it's a tough one to tackle and
something I think requires a lot of
nuance and an ability to separate the
final a product from the reality of the
production while the series had an
impressive pre-production phase the
ambitious nature of the series LED to
that privilege very quickly Vanishing
pushing for Non-Stop movie level
movement across a TV series is a big ask
and as the episodes began to air the
pressure began to mount and time very
quickly slipped away from the production
what began with a modest staff list
quickly ballooned culminating in a
finale that to get the episode Done
involved 24 animation supervisors 42
second key animators and worst of all 23
external Studios used for in-betweens on
top of mapa's own internal team to say
that things imploded is an
understatement getting those last few
episodes done on time was a gargantuan
effort that unfortunately put far too
many people in the same overworked
position mappa Productions are widely
known for some animators were forced to
hand in rough stick figure layouts for
second key animators to finish is due to
this punishing schedule static dialogue
scenes that would have been drawn in any
other scenario fell back on 3D models it
was extraordinarily tough but I think
the final results were clean enough to
be largely unnoticed by fans and it's
honestly somewhat of a Bittersweet tale
to talk about on one hand I enjoyed the
anime so so much and I think the final
results are great and speak for
themselves but at the same time it's the
Unseen that's concerning and I'll be
curious to see how things change going
forward based on lessons learned during
this production and based on the
feedback it's received around the world
the opening from shingo Yamashita a
wonderful director many will know from
Naruto Shippuden and his recent
Adventures into Pokemon and Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen is arguably the most perfect
distillation of what chainsaw man is as
a series many of its endings such as the
second one from Hitomi kiria showcase a
chainsaw man much in line with what my
initial expectations were filled with
fascinating colors and saturated
lighting they simply bring the quirky
joy of the manga get to life in a way
the anime doesn't quite accomplish all
the time there are components scattered
across the series that all lend
themselves well to what this animated
version of Chainsaw man could be with
further refinement and concessions made
for this unwavering Strife for realism
and I hope it's something that's
absorbed by the key staff moving forward
while producer sashimo has said many a
time that he's around to stop the show
from becoming too extreme and peculiar
so as not to prevent Mass Appeal I would
argue that that flies in the face of
what makes chainsaw man so special and
that going forward it would be great to
see further blending of these approaches
as noted individual directors have
already done so to great success in the
show already so why not push that
further and Elevate what comes next in a
way that Services both the drama and the
comedy and pays respect to just how
profoundly weird Fujimoto is
I think when all is said and done after
the hype dies down and the controversy
subside chainsaw man season 1 will be
remembered as a fun albeit restrained
adaptation of what is one of the most
experimental mainstreams Shonen series
around today while the efforts of
certain supremely talented episode
directors have elevated scenes to the
level of magnificence from time to time
I still can't help but think about what
could have been if this property was in
the hands of a slightly more
experimental series director the work
that was produced overall was very fun
but outside of certain directorial
choices with color and lighting I can't
tell if I love this season in spite of
the choices made or because of them
perhaps we won't ever truly know the
answer but at the end of the day it's
the difference between a good adaptation
and an excellent adaptation so I guess I
can't be too disappointed on that front
I mean hundreds and maybe even thousands
of different anime over the years would
have killed to have this kind of focus
and ambition behind it and who knows
maybe season 2 will take things in a
much more bold and eccentric Direction
but let me know what you guys think
that'll do it for this week as always
I've been totally not my Mark and thank
you all so much for watching
[Music]